hello hello congratulations yet again
thank you
all right so let's talk about your
history with pixar a little bit can you
name something about your approach to
scoring a pixar movie that has stayed
consistent from film to film but then
what's something about lightyear that
posed a unique one-of-a-kind challenge
for you
well i mean the the
the process is always the same whether
it's live action or animation and it's
about understanding the characters and
understanding the story and
understanding what these people are
going through
um it's it's it's you know
a lot of people think oh it's animated
so then you must do a particular thing
because it's animated and the truth is i
don't do anything different on a pixar
movie than i would do on a uh you know
mission impossible movie or a star trek
movie or a or a thing it's it's all
about
you know uh embracing these characters
understanding who they are
and why they do what they do and what
are the what are the trials and
tribulations and what are the struggles
and
the the sadness that they're going
through at the time it's like really
embracing that because i think that's
the only way to understand them as
humans the only way to connect to
somebody is to understand them and and
put yourself in their in their world in
their place so so that's always the
first thing um
and then the unique challenge on this
particular one which was different than
any of the other pixars i had to do was
the way we recorded it you know it was
done during the pandemic we weren't
allowed to be together
everything had to be done over zoom
i was recording musicians in a in a
studio with the musicians couldn't even
be together normally all the players
would be together close to each other so
the way we had to do this was separate
all the sections so you would have the
brass section who again normally would
be next to each other spread out six to
ten feet apart plastic sheets between
them they couldn't hear each other
properly
we had to find new ways to to mic the
room to get the sound we wanted because
it was for for years you've only done it
one way you know and that is to have
everyone together have all the things
happening at once and then suddenly we
were faced with this process of wait you
cannot do that you have to do it
differently how are you going to do it
and still get the same result and that
was a massive challenge but uh
i have a great team of people and warren
brown who was the engineer on this he he
killed it and we spent a lot of time in
the mix
really tweaking and figuring out how do
we get this to sound like it the way we
used you know uh so that was an enormous
challenge i think for everybody but uh
but we you know we got through it and
and and it worked out we learned a lot
in the process too so well that was
going to be my next question because as
someone who's always desperately
reaching for silver linings and
challenging situations is there anything
about kind of turning the process on its
head in that respect that you know
made you find like a corner of this
process or or a certain technique that
you never would have realized was usable
before that now you could take on to
future films even without copic
restrictions yeah i think so i think
there was a lot in terms of
understanding just technically space and
sound and how it projects and how it
works and how you can then do that but
more importantly i think it was one of
those things that in the beginning
you're like oh how is this ever going to
work it's not going to work
the real lesson is it can work
you just have to
make it work you know and and and when
an obstacle is in front of you you just
have to uh embrace the obstacle and make
it put a part of your team
and and make it work and i think that
you know in terms of what you can learn
from what we've all been through in the
last couple years is how did we adapt
you know and did you willingly adapt or
did you begrudgingly adapt and if you
willingly adapt and you ran forward
straight into it i felt like
you learned something about yourself and
i think i think that was something for
all of us that we you know it was uh and
we probably won't have the full
understanding of it for years to come
but uh you know yeah it was an
interesting way to go about things i
think about that quite often all right
so one thing about this movie that i'm
totally obsessed with is the idea of it
being a movie within a movie because you
know essentially what lightyear is to
andy that's what star wars and the mcu
movies are to us so considering you've
actually scored so many of those movies
is there anything from those scores that
you found influencing what you were
doing on light year so it had the same
effect on andy oh yeah it was a complete
love letter to all the movies i grew up
with watching absolutely so so the the
the music you hear in light years
is all taken from the years of
everything that i've listened to and
watched over the over the many years of
of you know consuming this sort of
entertainment which i love so much
uh it's absolutely all related to that
uh
but tied up in a nice new bow to put out
into the world so uh yeah there's a
there's a laundry list of movies i could
go through that that that are apart that
all at the heart and soul of light year
you know and i think you know and
everyone on the team felt the same way
about diving into it that way and it
certainly started with angus who is also
a massive fan of all of this stuff and
and being such friends with angus over
the years i i met him uh before the
incredibles actually worked on one man
band together
and uh and since then we've had so many
geeky conversations about every movie
you can imagine and this was just a
giant extension of that so
i'll wrap up with this one it's a it's a
bit of a broader question but obviously
if you you've worked on some of the
biggest film franchises out there you've
won an oscar you want an emmy and then
some but do you have a score that you're
just especially proud of that was maybe
for a movie that flew kind of under the
radar that you wish more people out
there were aware of
you know in that there's a couple of
them uh and it's it's not just the the
music that i'm proud of it's the movie
itself the movies you know like i always
feel like john carter got a bad rap i
feel like speed racer got a bad rap and
those two those are
those are two movies i absolutely love
and i feel like you know and i know that
they have their fan base they have their
ardent supporters which i'm very very
happy about uh but sometimes you know
you
you it's not you don't work any less on
a movie and work any less hard on a
movie uh everything you do is really
hard and you're always trying to make
the best thing you can uh so when it
doesn't quite hit the mark the way
you're hoping or when it's not received
the way you are you're always thinking
about you know god so many people worked
so hard on this thing and
and uh but the silver lining is all
those people that are that that are out
there in the world and through twitter
and the internet now you you know them
you know that it was embraced in a
certain way
uh and over time things get looked at
differently so
um those are probably two that come to
my head i think it doesn't really fall
into that category but inside out isn't
just my favorite pixar score it's one of
my favorite scores of all time oh thank
you that's quite that one i still
listened to it over and over thank you
so much i loved working on that film
pete doctor's the best
seriously one of the best of the best
this one is excellent as well huge
congratulations on this and everything
you've accomplished hope we get to talk
again soon thank you so much